في المدن والبلدات عبر منطقه الزلزال لا
تزال مشاهد الالم
مستمره في قريه على مشارف جماعه تلات
يعقوب باقليم الحوز الاكثر تضررا يمضي
ابراهيم ايط ناصر يومه محاولا اخراج ما
تبقى من اغراض من حطام منزله شقاء العمر
ذهب في لحظات وقع الزلزال دمر السقف وسقط
على رؤوس ابنائه وهم
نيام فكان بين القتلى الطفل سليمان ايت
ناصر يتذكر شقيق سليمان الراحل بانه كان
طفلا نابها ومحبا لاشجار التفاح واللوز
المحيطه بقريه لاتن يعقوب المطله على واد
نفيس في ذك اللحظه طلع الفيده وكان يشوف
الدنيا كامله كان يشوف الربيع وكان كيشوف
اشجار وكشوف شحال من
حاجه ما كانش يلعب ما كانش يلعب وا اخو يا
صير كان يلعب معه سكت قليلا
[موسيقى]
كله
قاله سياتي يوم وتبكي علي هكذا
قاله يروي معاذ الابن الاكبر لابراهيم ايت
ناصر كيف هرب عبر فجوه في سقف المطبخ
المنار وكيف حملت والدته شقيقه الاصغر
سليمان الى غرفه نومه بعدما غط في النوم
بغرفه المعيشه في منزل الاسره كان سليمان
على وشك بدء عام دراسي جديد قبل ان يعاج
له الموت ويغتصب احلام والديه كنا تعشينا
وهو ناس قلت لمراه دي هذا بلاصته باش ينعس
يرتاح ودات حت تما وسلات هذاك اللي سبق
نعس هو اللي وقع في هذك البيت ومازال
بحالك البيت فاش ترم عن الدروج فوق هذك
البيت درج هابتين عليه تقع قريه لاتن
يعقوب على بعد نحو 72 كيلومترا جنوبي
مراكش في جبال الاطلس الكبير وبالقرب من
مركز الزلزال وقد ضمرت العديد من المنازل
في القريه واغلقت الصخور الطرق مما جعل من
الصعب على عمال الانقاذ الوصول الى
المنطقه ساعد ابراهيم في انقاذ سته من
الجيران دفنوا تحت الانقاض ليله الزلزال
الكبير وانتشل العديد من الجثث ورغم
الماساه يعتزم ابراهيم واسرته البقاء
واعاده البناء وحث السلطات والجمعيات
الخيريه على تقديم يد العون لمساعده ضحايا
زلزال على اعاده بناء
حياتهم